sa demande et il patine c'est une
émission qui compte énormément pour moi
parce que c'est une de mes premières
télés ah ouais j'y suis allé et c'est
comme ça que j'ai pu rencontrer johnny
hallyday non mais j'avais fait
l'émission avec johnny hallyday
en fait parce que m6 j'avais été
transféré en fin de de nulle part et
miss est en fait comme il voulait mettre
le paquet sur moi parce que j'étais
jours le nouvel animateur de m6 il
m'avait invité dans le hit machine
j'ai les images et je sais pas pourquoi
je crois que c'est un pull si mes
souvenirs sont un jeu c'est bon j'ai mis
un peu l'on dirait que je viens de faire
des parties fait je prends si johnny
hallyday
[Applaudissements]
alors que d'avoir de vie merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté une fois de plus notre
invitation
ça nous fait très plaisir à chaque fois
c'est ça me fait plaisir d'être là tout
à l'heure on entendra la chanson le
temps qui passe comment sait comment ça
se passe avec eux campaci m'a proposé la
chanson le temps qui passe moi j'avais
la partie chantée à faire et eux avaient
la partie rap et affaires vous avez
passé l'inversé serait une catastrophe
ça tombe très bien parce que j'ai dit à
pacy écoute si tu me fais chanter ça va
bien parce que je ne sais pas rapper et
médine où sa tombe
ça tombe bien non c'est pas gentil vous
avez pas du tout un peuple
j'ai pensé la coiffure et pousser le
ballon
vaussion impressionné à côté en plus je
me rappelle il ya le patron de m6 qui
m'appelle la veille qui me dit bon on
bat m sur l'ut patine alors tu vas être
invitée principale ong des gens me
connaissent pas les lois mais c'est
important
c'est important pour coup de pouce c'est
le 10 et un moment et il ya johnny
hallyday qui m'arrive ok d'accord
d'accord on le fait cette émission
voilà je voulais me pousser merci en
tout cas m6 tout d'ordre à la d56 qui
sont toujours les mêmes depuis nettement
votre habillement stien mieux que celui
de charlie c'est aussi
des matins sur m6 on en a fait un loris
je pense que c'est la même que chez le
plus reçu le matin quand je faisais le
morning light is est acquis comme invité
pour l'instant derrière apple ou rim
mais on rigolait bande a rigolé grappin
la radio tu m'avais envoyé aller la
chercher
laurine t'inquiète pas on vient chercher
chez toi et tu m'as vendre il a cherché
en camion leur énoncé rechange et si
c'était lui le mec à poil dans laquelle
se retrouve et on va avoir du hier à la
télé bien autonome à venir sur l'amour
est dans le pré
on a des nouvelles rassurantes de loana
ce que vous avez enquêté les cherry on
aura le puissance 4 mains de la vérité
il adorait le puissance khatir on aura
le témoin du jour aussi c'est une jeune
dame qu'elle est commerçante dans les
yvelines
isabelle et qui décide qui a décidé elle
refuse lui de fermer son magasin
allemand de chaussures elle dit non ne
fermerait pas mon magasin il faudra
passer sur mac santiags a tout de suite
mais petite beauté
[Musique]
un seul homme a le pouvoir d'ordonner
telle attaque que j'ai voté pour ce type
c'est houphouet autant dire qu'on peut
plus avoir confiance en personne
il reste un homme peut-être dwayne
johnson bruce willis avec cette équipe
tangue va y avoir de l'action
jai jo conspiration ce soir à 21h15 sur
ces 8
c'est l'heure de votre soirée cinéma
avec mazda ne manquez pas votre moment
cinéma avec les café carte noire
sélection bio carte noire intensément
vivant
[Musique]
si tu cherches à être unique et
inimitable
à leur fonce exprime ton style
philips blade ton style tout simplement
rendre la vie meilleure est toujours
possible même jusqu'ici à l'emmental
coeur de meules président bien tendre
avec son petit goût fruité
c'est ça le secret de vos tartines
gourmandes et mata le coeur de meules
président quand on a vu que déplacer et
pour varier les plaisirs découvrez coeur
de me legrand d'affiner affiné six mois
pour un goût bien typés sans bet clic
sans batik semble qu qui lutte avec
betclic
[Musique]